hallo zusammen heute habe ich ein sehr
schnelles und super leckeres gries kokos
dessert für euch das ganze nennt sich
sultan loccumer an zutaten brauchen wir
einen liter milch 150 gramm puderzucker
40 gramm mehl 20 gramm speisestärke 100
gramm butter 100 gramm weichweizen gries
und 100 gramm kokosraspeln als erstes
geben wir die milch in einen großen topf
und dann wird das ganze mit dem mehl der
speisestärke und dem gries klümpchen
frei verrührt
dann schalten wir den herd ein und
lassen das ganze langsam aufkochen
dabei sollte man aber immer wieder
rühren weil es schnell passieren kann
dass die milch am boden anbrennt
wenn die masse aufgekocht ist und
einlegt nehmen wir sie vom herd und
rühren langsam die butter 1 bis alles
komplett geschmolzen ist das ist
momentan die konsistenz unserer masse
die wird aber gleich mit zugabe der
letzten zwei zutaten noch fester jetzt
geben wir den puderzucker hinein in den
originalrezepten nimmt man meistens
einen türkischen puddingpulver creme
shanti aber den nehmen wir hier nicht
weil da nicht jeder darauf zugreifen
kann
zu guter letzt kommen noch die
kokosraspeln hinein und werden gut
untergerührt
jetzt haben wir die basis für unser
dessert und das füllen wir in eine
schüssel um damit das ganze schnell
abkühlen kann
die masse decken wir jetzt an der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie ab und
lassen sie komplett auskühlen
bei kalten temperaturen könnt ihr das
fenster auch gerne auf dem balkon
abkühlen lassen
jetzt nehmen wir die gut durch gekühlte
masse umfang an zu dekorieren
ich habe mir hier 150 gramm kokosraspeln
bereitgelegt und in eine spritztour 150
gramm nutella rein getan um das ganze zu
formen nehme ich mir ein eis
portionierer und bevor ich dir meine
hände mit wasser
jetzt kommen wir erst mal kugeln und
drücken dann eine mulde in die kugel
das wälzen wir jetzt einmal rundherum in
die kokosraspeln und dann spritzen wir
noch ein hotel häubchen in die mitte
das rezept ist für 32 portionen
ausgelegt
falls ihr noch mehr orientalische
rezepte sehen wollt dann lasst mir gerne
einen kommentar da viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal auf
cookies kitchen